some breaking news now and two
residential properties in the south of
england have been searched after cctv
images of matt hancock
were leaked last month let's speak to
our political correspondent joe pike now
jane what more can you tell us
this information sarah has come from the
information commissioner's office
they are a government body that uh
trying to uphold data protection
legislation they're usually
looking into companies who've harvested
personal data or companies
they're not protecting customers data
now they have launched
an investigation into that alleged data
breach a breach of the data protection
act
when a video of then health secretary
matt hancock with his advisor gina color
d'angelo was leaked to the sun newspaper
and of course it led to mr hancock's
resignation from that very important
cabinet post the information
commissioner's office have told us today
that
investigation is ongoing that today they
searched two residential properties
in the south of england and that
computer equipment and
electronic devices have been seized so
an investigation
sarah is ongoing to see whether that
act has been breached if anyone can be
held to account
for it they say it's very important that
people know that their personal data
is kept secure and in this case it's
people being able to work in government
departments without a footage of them
moving
about can be released into the public
domain
they say though sarah they will not be
commenting further until their
investigation
has been concluded